wondering what recent star wars stories
might end up crossing over with obi-wan
kenobi when it premieres on friday may
27th curious who those villains are in
the teaser trailer we've got everything
you need to know before you see obi-wan
kenobi
like all disney owned properties this
hotly anticipated new series will stream
exclusively on disney plus it was
initially announced that obi-wan kenobi
would land on the streaming service on
wednesday may 25th 2022 which just so
happens to be the same release date as
the original star wars film disney plus
has recently planted its flag on
wednesdays since loki most of its series
have premiered on that day of the week
which has conditioned audiences to treat
these shows like appointment viewing
however on march 31st disney
unexpectedly announced that they had
pushed back obi-wan kenobi to friday may
27th thankfully they seem to have gotten
the right man to deliver the bad news
obi wan kenobi himself
i have some important news our premier
date is moving just a couple of days
from wednesday to friday may the 27th
they also disclosed that not one but two
episodes would become available that day
no official reason for the slight delay
was given though it's possible that the
change was made to coincide with the
star wars celebration in anaheim
california the event which had been
canceled the past two years due to the
pandemic returns on may 26th and
conference organizers have made it known
that some major star wars news will be
revealed on opening day
obviously the most exciting thing about
the series is the chance to see ewan
mcgregor back in action but the rest of
the cast of obi-wan kenobi sounds just
as promising joel edgerton who's racked
up quite the resume since his appearance
in star wars episode 3 revenge of the
sith returns to play uncle owen lars as
does bonnie peace as aunt beru but by
far the most talked about addition to
the lineup is hayden christensen who
will once again embody the iconic
villain darth vader one bit of casting
that rubbed some fans the wrong way is
that of rupert friend as the grand
inquisitor friend is a gifted actor but
the live action character design differs
somewhat from the much-loved animated
version voiced by jason isaacs who star
wars rebels fans hoped would get the
role regardless the breakout star of the
series may be moses ingram as riva
otherwise known as the third sister riva
a ruthlessly ambitious force sensitive
jedi hunter is someone we haven't been
introduced to before and show creators
are singing both the character and the
actors praises rounding out the cast we
have indra varma as an imperial officer
named tia and sung kong as the fifth
brother kumail nanjiani is also slated
to appear though his role hasn't been
officially disclosed it's also rumored
but not confirmed that jimmy smits may
have a cameo as bail organa
on disney investor day disney and
lucasfilms finally revealed the first
obi-wan kenobi teaser trailer giving
fans a glimpse of what to expect when
the show starts streaming on may 25th
the footage shows an older obi-wan
living alone in a cave on tatooine as he
keeps watch over a young luke skywalker
from there it also shows the inquisitors
hunting for someone most likely obi-wan
and interrogating some of the residents
on tatooine the new series will see our
jedi hero go up against these
inquisitors a squad of devout force
users who are loyal to the empire
they're not full sith lords but they're
not far off either
the dark side of the force is a pathway
to many abilities some consider to be
unnatural
the trailer also features scenes of riva
and the fifth brother in a dark
cityscape with neon signs lighting up
the area so clearly the series isn't
just going to stay on the sandy dunes of
tatooine for all six episodes
unfortunately it doesn't give us a look
at darth vader in action although his
iconic breathing ominously fades in as
the obi-wan kenobi title comes up at the
end of the trailer but a new still from
the series shows the villain surrounded
by shadows and according to returning
star hayden christensen fans will see a
very powerful vader
hopes for an obi-wan project go back to
disney's acquisition of star wars in
2012
the following year business insider
reported that then ceo bob iger planned
to produce several standalone star wars
films after a fan-made trailer for an
obi-wan film went viral the hollywood
reporter conducted a poll to see which
legacy characters audiences most wanted
to see in the proposed star wars stories
master kenobi was the clear winner and
news soon broke that an obi-wan spin-off
was being developed with director
stephen daldry attached then solo a star
wars story underperformed at the box
office triggering disney to put all of
its planned standalone movies on hold
the company was about to debut its new
streaming service and the star wars
story group turned its attention to
small screen projects most notably the
mandalorian at 2019's d23 event kathleen
kennedy confirmed that the obi-wan movie
was being retooled as a series deborah
chao who directed two highly rated
episodes of the mandalorian was hired to
helm all six episodes of obi-wan kenobi
and production was slated to begin in
2020.
ewing yes
are you going to play
obi-wan kenobi again
yes
however the series was paused once again
because of issues with the scripts after
the success of the mandalorian john
favreau and david filoni expressed
concern to deborah chao that the two
series plot lines were too similar a
major rewrite later by joby harold and a
covid delay later and obi-wan kenobi at
long last began filming in earnest in
2021
star wars lore is so dense and
far-reaching that even the most
well-versed fans sometimes have to
consult the galaxy's own timeline which
uses the battle of yavin from a new hope
as it's year zero obi-wan kenobi will
take place approximately 10 years after
the events of revenge of the sith and 9
years before a new hope or 9 bby at
which point the empire is at full power
that means luke skywalker is also
approximately 10 years old and it
implies obi-wan has been successfully
carrying out his mission to keep himself
and his young charge hidden for about a
decade this is the time period that
makes the most sense to explore for a
variety of reasons first off the clone
wars set around 22 to 19 bby fleshed out
pretty much everything that happens
between episodes 2 and 3. next mcgregor
is too old to portray obi-wan prior to
the prequel story and too young to
portray him in the events leading up to
rogue one a star wars story and a new
hope beyond that we canonically know the
least about what became of the jedi
master during this era which gives
series creators more flexibility with
the character and story arc other
significant star wars events that occur
around this time include solo around 13
to 10 bby and star wars rebels around
5-2 bby so it's not out of the question
that some plot lines from those projects
might intersect with obi-wan kenobi
the scripts for obi-wan kenobi underwent
some systemic revisions the hollywood
reporter suggests that the first batch
of drafts saw obi-wan watching over
young luke and evading darth maul
however dave filoni and john favreau
wanted deborah chao to take her series
in a different direction one that better
factored into the bigger star wars
picture and highlighted vader rather
than maul we probably know the least
about the story itself disney plus has
let slip virtually no details about the
plot in its promotional campaigns or
official descriptions we can piece
together that inquisitors are actively
pursuing jedi who manage to survive
order 66 and anyone resistant to the
empire who might possess force
sensitivity since we know that many of
the characters featured in the trailer
survive the events of the series to
appear in future installments it's
unlikely that showdowns between any of
these characters will serve as the
series primary purpose the trailers
advertise a fairly action-packed product
but as obi-wan can't really use his
lightsaber in public and almost everyone
is sure to make it out alive expect
obi-wan kenobi to be a little
existential the show will probably be
about his emotional journey as much as
it will be about running and hiding from
inquisitors
even people who've never seen a star
wars film know who darth vader is but
he's probably not the big bad of the
obi-wan series disney and lucasfilms
prefer to use vader in small doses like
at the end of rogue one or in select
episodes of star wars rebels
christensen's casting definitely
portends more screen time for the sith
lord and we know from an entertainment
weekly interview with mcgregor and
christensen that they do share scenes
together but it's established in a new
hope that the two haven't had much
interaction since they parted ways in
revenge of the sith their encounters
will have more impact if they're few and
far between inquisitors however aren't
familiar to every casual star wars
viewer and the marketing for obi-wan
kenobi is pretty inquisitor heavy
members of this special order within the
galactic empire use the force and often
wield red lightsabers but they're
technically neither jedi nor sith
their goal is to kill every jedi rebel
and force sensitive being that might
later become one or failing that convert
them to the dark side if the
inquisitor's extermination of the jedi
takes the four riva could be the primary
antagonist if not the highest ranking
one since the grand inquisitor has
already been the villain of a series in
which fifth brother appeared there is a
good chance they'll occupy something
like management roles with third sister
doing most of the empire's bidding
after spending a significant portion of
the skywalker saga the mandalorian and
almost the entirety of the book of boba
fett on the crime-ridden desert planet
in the outer rim territories even the
most nostalgic among us were getting a
little weary of tatooine as enthusiastic
as we were for an obi-wan series the
thought of enduring another six episodes
exclusively among moisture farms and
moss eisley was a real drawback but fear
not the creators of obi-wan kenobi have
engineered a way to get us off planet at
least twice the direct observes that the
trailer includes a pair of shots that
almost certainly depict the water moon
of ner the homeworld of the fortress
inquisitorius which is the headquarters
of the imperial inquisitor program we've
never been to nur or seen the fortress
in any live-action films or tv shows but
it's an important place in star wars
lore and its submerged armored recesses
certainly look cool obi-wan kenobi will
also be taking us to a brand new
location the planet daiyu which writer
joby harold describes as having sort of
a hong kong feel to it with a
graffiti-ridden nightlife
if you're looking to catch up or brush
up on star wars before the premiere of
obi-wan kenobi you may want to add the
clone wars to your next star wars movie
marathon a season 2 arc introduces the
dark saber and obi-wan's relationship
with duchess sateen and season five goes
deeper into both subjects which might
turn out to be relevant to the series
however with all these inquisitors loose
in the galaxy star wars rebels and the
video game star wars jedi fall in order
may provide a more substantive education
rebels follows a teenage thief turned
jedi in training ezra bridger who joins
up with a jedi master in hiding kanan
jarrus together with a crew of the ghost
they act as spies against the empire
while avoiding inquisitors the show
which lasted four seasons allows viewers
to get to know the grand inquisitor and
fifth brother better another story to
brush up on is star wars jedi fallen
order which takes place about five years
before obi-wan kenobi the game puts
players in the role of calcistas a
padawan who lives through order 66 and
becomes an inquisitor target it deals
more directly with the low morale of the
jedi and it contains a sequence set at
the fortress inquisitorius on ner if
there are any surprise cameos plot
twists or meaningful references the
smart bet is they'll come in the form of
a flashback to the clone wars or as
tie-ins to either rebels or jedi fall in
order
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you